one of my favorite parts of the show is
that you rarely speak in full sentences
so many of your reactions to what's
happening around you are facial and
weird guttural local reaction what's
that all about well she doesn't let me
speak but I have Gary's got kind of an
odd vocabulary with his noises like he
was called this season he was called a
[ __ ] mine which I loved yes and but he
kind of has these odd noises and that's
his vocabulary he'll just be coming oh
yeah
and imagine hearing that right here and
I give her a lot of information but it's
not really what I mean it's not so much
about the information for Gary I just
like to be close to her neck yeah what
are you doing why do you want to be it
almost in a pervy way you're constantly
Lena and what is it about that that
attracts Gary to Selena's neck crazy of
me yeah I'm a neck guy you know what do
you know gonna do we put together a
little quick montage of your reactions
Oh
Gary's reaction you'll see we're talking
about say it's fun to see a mashed up
take a look
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you really are vocabulary it's amazing
it's an amazing thing that Tony Hale can
do which is steal focus when he doesn't
have an actual line he figures out a way
[Applause]
you